en este vídeo vamos a practicar la
división entre un número de dos dígitos
digamos que tenemos cuatro mil 781
divididos entre treinta y dos pausa este
vídeo y trata de resolverlo y si hay un
residuo averigua cuál será el residuo
muy bien trabajemos juntos en esto en
primer lugar permítanme reescribir 4.781
y vamos a dividir esto entre 32 ahora
cada vez que dividimos entre un número
que tiene más de un dígito hacemos un
poco de arte la forma en que lo
abordaremos es un poco de prueba y error
usando la estimación así que empezaremos
diciendo
cuántas veces cabe 32 en 4 bueno 32 no
caben 4 entonces seguiremos adelante
cuántas veces cabe 32 en 47 bueno es
bastante claro que 32 cabe una vez en 47
así que pondré el 1 aquí por encima del
7 en el 47 y si te preguntas cómo lo
supe bueno solo recuerda 2 por 32 sería
igual a 64
eso es más que 47 de modo que 32 caben
47 una vez y multiplicamos 1 por 32 1
por 12 21 por 33 sabes que 1 por 32 es
32 y luego restamos 32 de 47 hagamos eso
y obtenemos que siete menos dos son 54
menos 3 es 1 y la forma en que te
aseguras de haber dado el paso correcto
es que todo lo que obtengamos aquí debe
ser inferior a 32 si lo que obtenemos
aquí es 32 o mayor
eso significa que podríamos haber tenido
un número más grande aquí pero luego
nuestro siguiente paso es bajar el 8 y
decimos cuántas veces cabe 32 en 158
ahora esto es un poco complicado si
estuvieras estimando cuántas veces cabe
30 en 150 podrías decir 5 y es
emocionante vamos a probar a ver si 5
funciona así que 5 por 2 es igual a 10
pondremos ser unidades y luego ponemos
una decena por allí llevamos 1
5 x 3 es igual a 15 1 es 16 eso no
funcionó casi funcionó pero no del todo
160 es más grande que 158 así que 5 es
demasiado grande por aquí así que
tenemos que cambiar hacia abajo a 44 por
2 es igual a 84 por 3 es igual a 12 y
ahora restamos 158 menos 128 8 menos 8
es igual a 0 cinco decenas menos dos
decenas es igual a tres decenas y no
tenemos centenas entonces esto es
correcto porque 30 es menor que 32 y
luego podemos bajar este 1 ahora cuántas
veces cabe 32 en 301 podríamos estar
tentados a decir bueno esto está cerca
de 30 y esto está cerca de 300 así que
tal vez sean 10 pero 10 por 32 es igual
a 320 por lo que sería demasiado grande
así que me siento bien con una
estimación de 99 por 2 es igual a 18
llevamos 19 por 3 es igual a 27
1 es 28 y luego podemos restar vamos a
tener que reagrupar aquí podrías hacerlo
en tu cabeza para pasar de 288 a 301
veamos sumamos 12 para llegar a 300 y
luego 1 más 13 así que podrías calcular
en tu cabeza que esto va a ser igual a
13 o podrías reagrupar podrías decir de
acuerdo veamos 1 es menor que 8 puedo
reagrupar desde la posición de las
decenas no no tengo nada allí así que
tengo que reagrupar desde la posición de
las centenas de modo que voy a tomar una
de las centenas me quedan dos centenas y
luego voy a tener diez decenas podría
tomar una de esas decenas así que me
quedan nueve decenas y pasársela a las
unidades ahora tengo 11 unidades y 11
menos 8 es igual a 39 decenas menos ocho
decenas es igual a una decena y luego
las centenas 200 menos 200 es igual a 0
y ahí lo tenemos esto es menor que 32 no
tenemos nada que bajar por lo que nos
quedamos con un residuo
entonces esto será igual a 149 con un
residuo de 13 y hemos terminado